good job the bell swept out feet swell
and you got a beautiful day gonna burn
my truck I'm going
I'm the wall
Oh
Bow Wow
hello wastelanders I'm Kate and I'm Dave
and today we're taking another look at
some of the best mods out there we're
far enough into January now that all our
new year's resolutions have been
forgotten we've definitely past the
deadline for sending out thank you cards
for Christmas and we really should have
taken that tree down but one thing
hasn't changed and that's how much we
love modding fallout even though the
official models aren't out yet so we're
going to look at some more of our
favorites today and we'd love you to
send in ones you loved or even ones you
made yourself with the hashtag GS
fallout we've got graphical overhauls
useful trackers and weapon mods in store
so sit down buckle up and get ready to
be impressed this isn't a standalone mod
it's actually a setting you can fiddle
with with one of your bog-standard EMB
mods to add a border to everything but
you end up with this quite attractive
borderland style cell shading the trees
look quite messy and it can look a bit
dark when everything has an outline but
if you're desperately looking for a way
to improve them fall out to low res
textures ahead of more in-depth mods
this might be the trick for you here's a
personal story that you can probably
relate to I'd been through most of the
way Sam picked up almost all of the
companions and chosen my favorite lovely
druggy Hancock I dressed him up gave him
sunglasses and sorry Nate my wedding
ring and we set off into the radioactive
sunset and then I met up with dog me or
something and accidentally sent Hancock
somewhere I haven't been able to find
him since is he wandering forever lost
did I send him to some distant outpost
is he dead if I had this companion
tracker it wouldn't have happened and we
could have lived happily ever after you
can't be everywhere at once despite the
Institute believing that they can and
working for centuries on making that
possibility so when you're millions of
settlements keep getting attacked by
poultry groups of raiders and your idiot
settlers managed to defend themselves
about as well as a hot dog defends
itself from being eaten what can you do
you can't drop everything you're doing
and go on to help some farmed or who
don't even know which way is up on a
pitchfork well then send robots of
course robots are better than people and
after all we honestly can't see how that
could go wrong we've all had our fun
giggling over a flame thrower with a
cryogenic freezing mod on it haha what a
paradox but why can't everything get a
cryogenic freezing mod in fact why can't
everything get every mod just imagine
the possibilities target seeking new
laser shot guns automatic missile
launcher anything you can dream you can
make as long as your dreams are all
about guns Luke's got nothing on the
lone wanderer at least not our modded
version of the lone wanderer who can
summon objects teleport and fly this
particular lone wanderer even has a
lightsaber which in reality is just a
recolor glowing sword isn't that what
lightsabers are anyway if you're more
partial to the dark side though don't
worry we've still got you covered
literally covered with this incredible
Darth Vader helmet you can even pair it
with a bathrobe that full Darth Vader
each effect we are only just scratching
the surface with these mods so far and
we're constantly impressed by how
creative the modding community can be
with the limited tools currently
available we can only imagine how
amazing fallout 4 is going to be once
for thurs de gives us proper modding
tools that there's two peas now it's
time to have a look at what you guys are
making inside and outside the game with
our community section remember to keep
your submissions coming in with the
hashtag GS fallout on Twitter our first
creation is an awesome Hancock statue
from Illya the ghoul sculpted from a
whole pound a half of super sculpey
polymer clay and with an awesome level
of detail everyone's favorite good
neighbor cool even has his trusty
Mentats and jet with him it seems like
there's a few vault dwellers out there
with a crush on Hancock but our new clay
friend isn't for sale so you can't add
him to your Hancock shrine sorry this
next piece from the fantastically named
PM me your vultures is a wonderfully
illustrated scene with Grandma and
Grandpa vault dweller cutting up the
Thanksgiving rad Roach with humans synth
and ghoul children hungrily waiting for
a slice of giant insect also there's
this really creepy dude staring out the
corner if you've grown envious of the
Brotherhood of Steel's air superiority
then this great video from many a true
nerd shows off their very own Flying
Fortress complete with its own cannons
captain's cabin a plank to walk and it's
even more to a lighthouse just in case
you were worried that it floats away
whilst you were roaming the wastes I
recommend checking out the full build
and showcase on the many a true nerd
channel that's all we have time for this
week I'm going to attempt to build my
own flying home without falling out of
the sky and shattering my shins too many
times but if you have any awesome builds
you want to show off
make sure you tweet them at us with the
hashtag GS fallout I'd like to thank you
for sharing and subscribing to the
fallout show and stay safe out there
wastelander